sau năm nay là việc hình chương nghiên túc, dân chủ và chất nghiệp hiệu quà,
chương này đây hôm nay biểu tòan Quốc lần thứ 4 của đàn đã bị mạc.
Hòan thành còn độ nộ dúc chương trình đe ra.
Rựa phía nấu mạc có các đồng trí lắng đạo,
nguyên lắng đạo đàn, nhà nước, Quốc hội, chính phủ,
quý bán mà chận tuộc Quốc Việt Nam, các đồng trí quên quý viên tổ trí trị,
quý viên Trung ngân đàn, các mẹ Việt Nam anh không, các nhân sĩ, chiế thức,
các tuộc trức tuần giáo và các loàn khác quốc tế.
Đây hồi buổi bún diễn ra trong mối cảnh đất nước đứng trước những thời cơ
vẫn hồi mối, đàn xanh, không ít khó khăn thách thức,
yêu cầu phát triển nhàng, bình vẫn lần cao chất lượng tăng trường,
cùng Quốc phòng ăn liên, lấy mạnh hộ nhập khúc tế, ngày càng đặt ra,
yêu cầu cao hơn, đối với vải trò lĩnh đạo của đàn.
Với tình thành đoàn kết, dân chủ, kỳ cường, luật phá phát triển,
Đây hồi đã thực sự trở thành đột xinh hoạt chính trị xấu dọng trong toàn đàn,
toàn dân và toàn quân.
Chồng xuất thời gian là việc,
này hồi đã tập trung thảo luật,
đón gốc vều ý kiến tâm hước,
chức nhận chỉ tòa vào các dự thảo văn kệch chính đại hồi.
Các văn kệnh được chình bị công phu,
kết tình chỉ tòa của toàn đàn, toàn dân, toàn quân,
và nãy đầy đủ thực tiến xinh động của đất nước.
Đồng thời sẽ định gió phương hướng,
một tiêu diện vụ và các dải pháp lớn cho những kỳ tối,
và tâm diện dài hạn.
Đây hồi đã thung nhất cao, thung qua các văn kệnh,
tâm chính chỉ mạnh mẽ trong việc kết tục đầy mạnh quan dịch.
Đồng bộ công cuộc tối mới,
xây dựng và bảo vệ vấn chắc tụ quốc Việt Nam só hội trường,
một dự dưng đặc biệt quan trọng của đại hồi.
Là công tác nhân sự của bàn chức hành trường vương khoả mười vốn,
với tình tàn dân chủ khách quan, mình bàn,
đại hồ đã sáng xuất lợi trọng bàn chức hành trường vương mới,
vùng hai chăm đồng trí,
trong đó một chăm tắm mười,
quý vinh thích thích hai mười quý vinh dự quết,
lây là những đồng trí thương mìo về bàn lĩnh chính chỉ,
phẩm chất đạo lức,
năng lực lĩnh đạo vào vỳ tính,
bảo đảm sự kế thừa,
hồn định và đổi mới,
đáp ở nếu cầu lĩnh đạo lức lước trong dài đoạn phát triển mới,
tà hồi gỳ lần thứ nhất màn chất hành trường vương đàn,
quá mười muốn,
đã bầu mộ chính chỉ,
vùng người chính đồng trí,
đồng trí tổ lần kết tục lực kính nhật,
bầu giữ trước tổng bý thư,
bởi một chăm phần chăm của yvên trường vương tán thành,
hồi gỳ bầu bán bý thư,
vùng người bà đồng trí,
vùng người quý vinh bầu chính chỉ,
đo được mộ chính chỉ phần công tham gia bàn bý thư,
và bà đồng trí được bầu tài hồi gỳ lần thứ nhất,
đồng trí tình cảm tủ,
được mộ chính chỉ phần công dự trích thân trực bàn bý thư,
bài hồi cung đá bầu quý bán kìm chà trường vương,
khoá mười muốn,
vùng hà bà đồng trí,
đồng trí trần xí thành,
quý vinh bầu chính trí,
bà bầu tần quốc lần thứ mùi muốn của đàn,
đá thành công rất tốt đẹp,
bánh giấu một móc sòn lưỡi trong lịch sử đá công sản Việt Nam,
bà lịch sử hào vùng của rất tộc Việt Nam,
tổng vý thư nếu gió,
tình thần xuyên xuất của những tỷ đại hồi mùi muốn,
là tự trụ trín lực,
đám trắc thời cơ,
trung sức đồng lòng,
vượt qua mọi thách thức,
khơi dạy mạnh mẹ khát vọc phát triển,
vuyến ý trí thành thành đậu,
vuyến quyết sách thình kết quả cú thẻ,
nổi là làm làm ngày làm đúng làm quyết liệt làm biến cùng và làm hiệu quả.
Đại hồi, đám thảo lận của thông qua những chủ trường quyết sách
và các phương hướng lớn,
các nghiệp vụ trong tâm,
các bà phát triển lực để xây dực phát triển nhang về vướt đất nước,
bà vệ bứng chắc tổ cú phy tâm sổ chúngier trong bối cảnh mới,
trong đó rất định phát triển kinh tế sau,
bà vệ mua trường là chung tâm,
xây dực đàn của la thén chốt,
phát triển văn hóa con người là nền tàn.
Tăng cường của phòng anh linh và đẩy mạnh đối ngoại
hồi nhập là trong yếu kinh phuyên,
đồ phát triển phọc,
công nghệ ở mối xanh tạo,
trên đồ rối của ra đậu lực chúng tâm của phát triển.
Đại hồi nhấn mạnh yêu cầu trên kỳ sở kinh đình
đức vấn đề có tính vình tắc,
phải bám sách thực hiện,
không đừng đổi mối,
cải cách để phát triển nhang và bình bứng đất nước.
Tinh thần kinh đình chính đem bạn linh chính trị,
là sự tiếp nối mạnh mồn lịch sử,
và những mài học từ công cuộc đổi mối,
là lời tham kết mạnh mẽ của đàn,
trong bất cứ hoàn cạnh nào,
cũng luôn luôn kinh đình,
mục tiêu đặc lập xanh tạo,
đánh liên với chúng ta hồi,
kinh đình con đường lực trụ,
tự cường,
luôn đặt lưỡi quốc gia xanh tạo,
linh trên hết,
trưa hết,
tắt em nó vài phục của nhé rất ở vỡi chi,
chục tâm,
tình thần lổi mối,
là yếu cầu măng tính thời đại,
không đổi mối, cải cách thì không thể bất phá,
không thể cạnh tranh, không thể phát triển,
phải tiếp tục lổi mối từ rin,
đổi mối mối hình phát triển,
mối hình tăng trở,
đổi mối biệt pháp tổ chức thực hiện,
để đường lối đúng,
trở thành kết quả của thẻ trong cuộc sống.
Tổng bị thư yêu cầu tổ chức đàn các cấp khẩn trường khoản triển,
học tập thể chế hoá cụ thể hoá trên khai từ kết đồng bộ,
tôn dịch,
yêu quả các đủ dùng pân kết đại hồ,
mỗi người thách mọi đồng lực,
phát vui sức mạnh khủy đại đồng kết,
tôn dân tổng,
thực hiện thống lợi các buộc tiêu,
như buộc đại hồn lợi ra.